مجددا وانطلاقته مع اليوفيتا تاجل رفع
الفاران يعلن اعتزاله على انستجرام هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
مع وصول الموسم الى مراحله الحاسمه طمئن
البرازيلي غبريل
ارسنال بعد صوره على انستجرام وهو يتدرب
بالكره وشارك جيزوس الصوره مع متابعه وكتب
قائلا اخيرا بعد ثمانيه اسابيع وهي المده
التي غاب فيها عن الملاعب بسبب الاصابه
وستمثل عودته اضافه قويه لارسنال الذي
يبدو في الطريق الصحيح للفوز بلقب الدوري
الانجليزي
الاخبار السيئه على الجماهير يوفنتوس بعد
الاعلان عن اصابه مجددا لتتاخر بدايه
اللعب الفرنسيه مع نادي الشمال الايطالي
ولو شارك بوغبا في اي مباراه رسميه مع
اليوفي منذ انتقاليه اليه الصيف الماضي قد
تلقى الضوء الاخضر من الاطباء للمشاركه
وفعلا تم استدعائه في المباراه الاخيره
للفريق امام مونزا لكنه بقي على مقاعد
البدلاء
نبقى مع اخبار نادي يوفنتوس الذي يعاني من
خصم النقاط وتراجع نتائج ايضا لعبوا سيده
العجوز طلبوا اجتماع الطارئه من الاداره
لمناقشه الوضع الحالي للفريق خاصه وان
عقود عدد اللاعبين ستنتهي في الصيف المقبل
بالاضافه الى ابتعاد الفريق عن المراكز
المؤهله لدوري ابطال اوروبا وهو الامر
الذي قد يدفع بعض النجوم للتفكير في
الخروج من النادي
في خبرين الاخير اعلن مدافع منتخب فرنسا
اعتزاله اللاعب دوليا رغم انه في الثلاثين
من عمره فقط وكانت ديشون يفكر في منح
اشاره القياده لفران بعد اعتزال اوغو
لوريس لكن لاعب مانشستر يونايتد فجاه
الجميع بعد نشره الخبر عبر حسابه على موقع
انستغرام